HBO's new miniseries Chernobyl recounts
the 1986 nuclear disaster in Ukraine
it's a dramatization so while many
events depicted in the show are based in
reality it had a few discrepancies with
historical accounts here are 12 of them
see that thick pillar of black smoke
that's coming out of the power plant it
makes for an ominous shot but in reality
it was more likely thin trails of white
vapor that were escaping from the
reactor in Episode one Game of Thrones
fans might have recognized donald Sumter
the actor who played maester Luwin it
turns out that his character in
Chernobyl an elderly Bolshevik by the
name of Zarkov is fictional his speech
urging officials not to raise alarm
about the accident that's also a
fabrication no one leaves and cut the
phone lines contain the spread of
misinformation that doesn't mean there
wasn't some effort to contain the spread
of information in the immediate
aftermath of the meltdown but we don't
know if what Zarkov says here accurately
reflects the government's rationale at
this point in time Chernobyl is the
biggest nuclear accident to date but
according to Jan haverkamp a senior
nuclear energy expert at Greenpeace
Lagasse's comparison of Chernobyl to
Hiroshima doesn't quite make sense the
fire were watching with our own eyes is
giving off any twice the radiation
released by the bomb in Hiroshima the
bomb dropped on Hiroshima was so
devastating because of the number of
people that suffered direct exposure to
radiation at Chernobyl on the other hand
radioactive material enters atmosphere
and disperses so it's health effects
were more indirect and long-term
in Episode two a helicopter crashes as
it flies over the open reactor there was
a helicopter crash in the wake of
Chernobyl but the show moved this event
up chronologically the crash actually
took place in October of that year
months after they were done fighting the
fire of the fictional characters in the
show the most central is Ilana home yuk
the scientists from the Belarusian
Institute for nuclear energy home yuk
travels to Chernobyl uninvited
interrogate the plant supervisors in
their hospital rooms and soon enough
even finds herself in the presence of
general secretary Gorbachev if that
storyline seems unrealistic for one
person it's because home yuk was
imagined as a composite character to
represent the many scientists who led
the cleanup effort her gender is
definitely realistic as the USSR had an
impressive record of training women for
stem roles in Episode two homie ik warns
the council that a second explosion
could occur ejecting even more
radioactive material from the core at a
force of up to four megatons
according to Haverkamp that estimate is
probably an exaggeration the rest of her
description doesn't quite hold up either
unlikely be fatal to the entire
population of Kiev as well as a portion
of Minsk and will impact all of Soviet
Ukraine Latvia Lithuania Belarus eeeh as
well as Poland Czechoslovakia Hungary
Romania and most of his journey the
assertion that all of Europe would be
affected involves a lot of hypotheticals
as Haverkamp says that situation might
play out if all of the melt and khorium
hit ground water but when khorium starts
melting it does so in a very uneven way
so if the second explosion had actually
occurred it'd be pretty difficult to
predict the fallout
as part of the effort to prevent the
steam explosion that homi accord about
three patriotic volunteers dive into
radioactive water to open the tank
valves the show takes a few liberties
here according to one of the divers
Alexei Annan enco they didn't all
volunteer for the job Annan nkow was an
engineer at the plant who simply
happened to be on duty that day when his
supervisor assigned him to the mission
he was told he could refuse the
assignment but he was the only person on
the shift who knew the location of the
valves leaving him with effectively no
choice but to join the team of divers in
one of the series more comical moments
the miners digging the tunnel underneath
unit 3 strip naked took hope with the
heat it's possible that a few of the
miners actually did this but even the
show's writer and creator Craig Mazin
said that there were some varying
accounts of how much clothing got taken
off one of the sources at Mazin
consulted was midnight in Chernobyl a
book based on real accounts of the
accident compiled by journalist Adam
Higginbotham in an interview with
inverse Higginbotham said the show
exaggerated the denial and delayed
response of the Soviet government his
book describes how the investigation
into Chernobyl began almost immediately
on several fronts within 36 hours of the
explosion reactor specialists traveled
to Chernobyl from Moscow and were able
to promptly identify the most likely
cause of the accident
therefore as Higginbotham said there was
no need for a crusading whistleblower to
uncover the causes but raising awareness
about the problems that led to Chernobyl
did take Soviet scientists several years
of hard work and research sadly the
friendship we see developed between
Boris cher bina chairman of the
Chernobyl Commission and Valery legassik
the chief scientific investigator was
largely an imagined one the duo scenes
together show their growing bond but
there's no evidence that any of these
scenes actually happened look off was
also not quite the martyr figure that
Jared Harris
pics raising his voice to Gorbachev an
openly challenging the head of the KGB
we have no reason to think that the
trial of Dyatlov and the other two plant
managers involved any of the theatrics
seen in the finale when legassik
denounces his government in front of a
room of officials the gossip did die by
suicide two years after the explosion
and he did dictate a final letter
reflecting on the liquidation effort he
spearheaded but in this message he
didn't ask what is the costs of lies the
show's tagline nor did he contemplate
any abstract questions about the meaning
of truth the real danger is that if we
hear enough lies then we no longer
recognize the truth at all the goshawk
did have concrete grievances about the
handling of chernobyl which he outlined
in great detail in his message did we
miss anything let us know in the
comments
you